VR。まあいろんなVRがあると思います
プレステ4のVRもあるし、スマートフォンのVRもある
VRってさつけると仮想世界、現実とは違う世界に
行っているこの感覚が味わえるので、
ちょっとね、感覚がおかしくなる気がするんですよ
なので今回は
僕がVRをつけて感覚が...
あーくしゃみ出る
あー
画伯（？）がおかしくなるじゃぞやろうと思います
名付けて
もし
やー怖いんすよ実際VRって
分かんないですからねぇ
これはスマホにつけてやるやつなんですけど
現実と山梨（？）
現実世界との区別がつかくなったらそこで終わりですから
今回はその持ってかれた人です僕は
僕はVRをやり過ぎて
向こうの世界に持ってかれた人間
現実世界に意識は無く、
もう仮想世界、向こうの世界に意識が行ってしまってて、
この世界にもう僕の魂は無いわけです
僕の亡骸だけがそこに残っている状態で、
後輩はどうやって僕を現実世界に戻すのか
もしかしたら放置するかもしれませんね
そこは分かんないんですけど、
だからVRを...
VRを付けて僕が向こうの世界に持ってかれた時の
後輩の反応を今回見てみたいと思います
いや心配してくれるとと思いますよ
最近ずっとファイナルファンタジーやってるからね
あっちの世界に持ってかれてもおかしく無い
早速向こうの世界に行ってみようと思いますよ
7時22分？
いや6時50分です
あれ？嘘
早く無い？
やばいよ、
やばいらしいよ、これ
(なぜ脱いだし)
マジでやばい、マジでやばい、マジな奴だこれ
うわー
マジマジマジマジだこれ
うわマジか
あ↓あー↑あ↓あー↑そう言う事
えっヤバ(語彙力)
やばいっしょ
やばいやばい
うおー
これヤバ
やばいよね、それ
スゲーこれ
how about aquarium?
(アクアリウムって元素みたいだな)
あっ
わ魚！
HAHAHA
さ、魚すごいいる
うわヤバイ
うわしっぽー
昔の買い手だよ(??)
多分
髪ww
ふんっ
彼は笑っているが、
この時すでにもやしは
仮想世界に魂が移動してしまってる
ヘッヘッヘw
笑っている場合では無い
今のもやしにどれだけ話しかけても
彼がこたえる事は無いだろう
SOU
彼は今、
ただの亡骸になってしまったのである
(どうしてそうなったw)
なってはいない
写真を撮っている場合では無い。笑ってる場合でも無い
ターゲットはもやしを起こそうと、色々試して見たのだが
どれも効果が無かった
なぜなら今のもやしには
魂が無いからだ
そう言う...システム？
どう言うシステムなのだ
あっ
(こっち見んなし)
バレてしまった
やられた。なんか光ってんなって
やられたー。クッソwwwww
だが、カメラを見つけた所でもやしに魂が戻ってくる事は無かった
引き続き色々試して見たが、
はj...もやしの魂が戻って来る事は無かった
あっ
奇跡的に一瞬魂が戻った様だ
その後も色々試したが、
もやしが起きる事は無かった
彼は何をしているのだろうか
そして彼は新幹線の時間がきて、
魂が抜けて亡骸となったもやしを部屋に放置し、
帰ったのであった。
そしてもやしは、トイレに行きたくなり、起きたのだった
(世界で一番酷いドッキリ)
ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑
ぺー→ぺぺ↑ぺ↑ぺー↑ぺー↓
ぺ↗︎ぺ↓ぺ↓ぺーーーー↗︎ ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺー↗︎ぺー↓
ぺ→ぺ↓ぺ↓ぺー↗︎ぺー↑ぺ↓ぺ↓
ぺ→ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺー↓ぺー↑ぺーーーーー↓（ぺーっ↑ぺーっ↓ぺーっ↓ぺっ↓）
ぺ・ぺ・ぺ・ぺん☆﻿